this episode is brought to you by
curiositystream get free access to
nebula the streamy nominated platform
built by and for creators when you sign
up for curiosity stream at the link
below
[Music]
as the world rolls into its ninth month
of the pandemic many countries face
rising cases and record daily case
numbers
the united states alone accounting for
nearly 10 million infections and almost
a quarter of a million dead since march
as i predicted would be the case in a
previous video kovit is still very much
a threat
and we've seen a new surge of cases as
the country moves into the autumn season
but though we're certainly not out of
the woods yet and it would be foolish to
think otherwise
there is a small glimmer of hope that we
could see an effective vaccine in the
very near future
in this episode we're going to look at a
promising vaccine that could be approved
for emergency use as early as december
but we'll also consider the very real
concerns with its distribution
cost and the tremendous profits u.s
corporations stand to make from the
suffering of innocent people
on monday november 9 american pharma
giant pfizer announced that a clinical
trial
of their coveted vaccine had proved more
than 90 effective that's a promising
figure
especially given the fact that the virus
has already killed more than 1.2 million
people around the world and a medical
solution is desperately needed
this particular vaccine developed in
partnership with the german drug company
biontech
was not one of the original nine
candidates developed at the world health
organization's covax research facility
which aimed to develop a vaccine that
could be produced and fairly distributed
to populations around the world
this will be important later if pfizer's
trial results are accurate
a 90 prevention rate would put this
vaccine on par with other important
drugs like the childhood measles vaccine
as far as we know or at least as far as
pfizer has revealed
there are no serious health risks
associated with their drug
they are still in the required two-month
period of collecting drug safety data
but if everything checks out we can
expect pfizer to request fda approval
for emergency use later this month
with initial rollout potentially
beginning as early as december
company executives have claimed that by
the end of the year they'll have
produced enough of this vaccine to
immunize 15 to 20 million people
this isn't the only vaccine in late
stage trials pfizer's drug is only one
of 11 separate trial vaccines
four of which are based in the u.s since
the virus entered the global spotlight
there's been a flurry of activity as
pharmaceutical companies around the
world try to figure out a solution
some with the partnership of the world
health organization and others without
as with any new and critically important
drug independent scientists have
cautioned that we don't know enough
about it yet
there's still much data to be collected
and we can't even be certain that
pfizer's offering will yield permanent
immunity
this information will become available
as the clinical trials progress
and the trial is projected to end 164
people out of the 44 000 participants
have developed covid19
with the current rate of infection in
the us that shouldn't take long
now like just about every aspect of
modern life the business of vaccine
production has been twisted by politics
one federal campaign operation warp
speed offered pfizer 1.95 billion
dollars to deliver 100 million doses of
coveted vaccine to the federal
government
which would supposedly be distributed to
the american people free of charge
at the time this was the largest such
offer from the us government
pfizer executives have attempted to
distance themselves from any kind of
political deal making
saying we were never part of the warp
speed we have never taken money from the
us government or from anyone
that sounds reassuring until you realize
that they absolutely have taken money
from the us government
specifically over half a billion dollars
in public subsidies and assistance
pfizer is not exactly known for their
honesty or ethics
in 2009 the company set a record for the
largest healthcare fraud settlement and
the largest criminal fine in american
history
2.3 billion dollars i think it's worth
suggesting that maybe we should treat
their press releases and other claims
with skepticism
at the end of the day pharma giants like
pfizer exist to make profits
and there are few things more profitable
to a drug company than a worldwide
pandemic that demands a solution
this brings us to the most critical
questions regarding the vaccine
how much will it cost and who will be
able to get one well
if we take pfizer ceo albert borla at
his word the vaccine will be available
for
free to all american citizens that
sounds great until you realize that 14
of the people living in the us aren't
citizens if you want to ensure that the
entire country is immunized from future
kovid spikes
you have to vaccinate as many people as
possible if pfizer or whoever ends up
developing the final vaccine
is able to produce enough of the drug to
immunize everyone in the country
we need to immunize everyone in the
country there is no reason to
arbitrarily leave people susceptible to
infection when the virus doesn't care
about your citizenship
obviously there will always be those
obnoxious people who refuse to get
vaccinated even when the vaccine is
proven safe and effective
but that is a much smaller portion of
the population than 14
if we truly want to immunize our country
we have to make sure that everyone who
is willing to get vaccinated has the
ability to do so
of course this statement by borla could
just be him misspeaking
he may very well have meant that every
person living in the united states will
have access to the vaccine for free
if that's the case great i applaud them
for that decision
but i'll remain skeptical until the
vaccine is actually available
this skepticism is based on prior
behavior by american pharmaceutical
companies
in the united states we suffer under a
ridiculously expensive for-profit
healthcare industry
need a ride to the hospital that'll cost
you about a thousand bucks
want to hold your baby after it's born
40 bucks which you'll be lucky to have
left over after paying over ten
thousand dollars to have the baby even
if you have good health insurance it'll
cost you over four thousand dollars
if you think this would change during a
pandemic you don't understand how
capitalism works
let's take the pharma company gilead for
example way back in 2009
gilead began researching and developing
a drug called rem desevere which was
intended to be used to fight hepatitis c
it went on to be considered as a
potential ebola treatment in 2013 and 14
and most recently was deployed to treat
the symptoms of coronavirus earlier this
year
upon the news of kovid's arrival gilead
stock rose nine percent in pre-market
trading
the company also maintains a complete
monopoly on the drug
and the u.s snatched up every single
dose for several months
if you'd like to see a more in-depth
look at gilead and remdesavir i've made
a video on the subject
but the short version is this rem
desevere has proven to be a fairly
effective way to treat coronavirus in
hospitalized patients
it has no effect on mortality rates but
for those who do recover the drug tends
to shorten the recovery time by about
four days in the hospital or 31
the treatment consists of a five-day
series of iv drips utilizing six vials
of rem desevere
the cost of those vials five hundred and
twenty dollars each
for a total cost of three thousand one
hundred and twenty dollars
there's also a reduced government price
which applies to a very limited number
of people
and does not include those on medicare
or medicaid those most vulnerable to
getting seriously ill from the disease
the price for those lucky few three
hundred and ninety dollars per vial
for a total cost of two thousand three
hundred forty dollars
so in the middle of a pandemic with tens
of millions of people without insurance
or a paycheck
the only available treatment cost two to
three thousand dollars
forty percent of americans couldn't pay
for one single day's worth of rendezovir
how are they supposed to afford five
days of that on top of the incredibly
expensive hospital stay
and before you say that's just gilead
recouping their r d costs
nope the drug's development was funded
by the us government using u.s taxpayer
dollars
the treatment could be free a group of
experts crunched the numbers and found
that gilead could turn a profit by
charging just 10 dollars for the
treatment
10 300 times less than what they're
charging
yeah but they could make more money this
is how pharmaceutical companies operate
they accept government funding deny that
they've done so
make promises they won't keep and when
their product is ready
they'll slap a multi-thousand dollar
price tag on it it remains to be seen
whether this will be the case for
pfizer's covid vaccine
pfizer is pretty widely reviled as a
company completely devoid of decency
so i wouldn't be surprised to see a
steep fee attached to their drug
we won't know for sure until next year
we might see an early version of the
vaccine used in emergency cases but
according to pfizer's roadmap the
official rollout of the final vaccine
for at-risk populations should occur in
the late first quarter or early second
quarter of 2021.
one final red flag is the company's
claim that they have a quote
acute funding gap of 4.5 billion dollars
that could slow access to the vaccines
in low
and middle-income countries this seems
to indicate that pfizer is willing to
hold the drug hostage until someone
coughs up another huge round of funding
effectively ensuring that they make a
healthy profit off the vaccine
americans tend not to care about other
countries so as long as u.s residents
are provided the vaccine
it will likely go unnoticed if pfizer
sits on a massive stockpile of vaccines
until other countries pay their
exorbitant ransom
pfizer looks like the good guy for
providing supposedly free vaccines to
americans
and the rest of the world continues to
fight the disease until pfizer is happy
with the pile of money they've
accumulated
this is not how it should happen any
eventual covid vaccine should be made
available to every person who wants one
the profits of a single company should
not determine who lives and who dies
at some point we need to realize that
there are things more important than
money
and human life is one of them
if you've watched my last few videos
you'll have noticed that youtube has
been demonetizing a lot of them
that's why some of my creator friends
and i teamed up to build nebula a
streaming platform built by
and for youtubers like me so we don't
have to worry about demonetization
since nebula is all about creating
thoughtful content we've partnered with
curiositystream an established streaming
platform with a solid track record of
caring about great educational content
and the financial security of those who
produce it
curiosity stream is an online streaming
service with thousands of non-fiction
titles from some of the best filmmakers
in the game
you can find tons of great episodes like
coronavirus race for a vaccine which is
a great watch if you enjoyed this video
as educational creators ourselves we
love curiositystream
so we've worked out a deal where if you
sign up for curiositystream at the link
below you'll also get access to nebula
100 free for a limited time curiosity
stream is offering 26
off their annual plan that's less than
15 bucks a year for both curiosity
stream and nebula
which in my humble opinion is a pretty
great deal since we're all stuck inside
anyway
why not spend some time learning about
fascinating topics on curiosity stream
or check out nebula's original content
including my upcoming series on the
resurgence of fascism
you can also watch all my videos as they
were intended ad free
there really is something for everyone
and by signing up at the link below
you're helping us produce more content
without the fear of demonetization
give curiosity stream a shot and get
free access to nebula when you sign up
using the link below
it really does help support my channel
and educational creators all across
youtube
if you enjoyed this video and you'd like
to see more like it consider subscribing
to stay up to date with my latest
episodes
if you hated it go ahead and drop a
thumbs down you can check out my
previous episodes by clicking the links
on your screen
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next week